I'm gay and 31 can i still be a success
so I got a great question a really sad
question from one of my youtube viewers
love you guys vinod who wrote in the say
dear Evan I enjoy watching your videos
now I want to build a business empire I
can't focus because my personal problems
I'm gay went through an arranged
marriage with a girl now on the verge of
divorce finally I've decided to move on
I'm 31 now am I too late to get back on
track thanks for not this is a super
important question and again one that
that makes me sad because as
entrepreneurs we all have these limiting
beliefs we live in this world and we
tell ourselves stories that hold us back
from becoming a success becoming the
person that we want to become achieving
the goals what we want to achieve so
here's Vinod telling himself that he's
gay so he can't be successful well what
about Calvin Klein what about lady gaga
what about Ellen DeGeneres he's telling
himself that because he's 31 years old
he won't be successful well what about
Harland Sanders who took his last shot
at KFC when he was in his 60s what about
Ray Kroc who launched McDonald's when he
was in his 50s and had diabetes and
arthritis and kidney failure and the
best years were behind them right these
are just stories that you tell yourself
and we all have them we tell ourselves
that we're too young we're too old we
don't we don't live in a rich country I
don't live in the city I don't live in
in you know whatever state or province I
didn't go to Harvard I didn't get an
education I didn't even complete high
school and therefore i won't be
successful it happened to me when I was
in my first business I was 19 years old
I was selling to people three times my
age and I thought they're never gonna
listen to me i'm 19 i don't know
anything and it wasn't until I busted
through that limiting personal belief I
busted through that story I was telling
myself that I started to achieve success
because as long as you believe that
being gay and being 31 as old that you
want to achieve success than you're
you're you're right if you believe
that's true then it's going to be true
and the way to break through
now every every big growth you're going
to have when your life and your business
is going to come from busting through a
limiting personal belief if you're here
right maybe you've grown a little bit
now you're here you haven't had success
you haven't had momentum you can't just
keep doing the same things it's going to
be from changing something and typically
that comes from breaking one of your
limiting personal beliefs so how do you
do it how do you bust through it's so
important because you've created an
environment that tells you that all
these things are true maybe your
marriage didn't work out right you're
getting divorced and so that being gay
had an impact obviously right and now
maybe you tell yourself I won't be
successful in marriage anymore and maybe
that translates I won't be successful in
business anymore the people you surround
yourself with your friends potentially
your family the books you read the the
videos you watch everything that you
have in your environment now is holding
you where you are is confirming that
that story is true and lets you continue
to believe it and as long as you believe
it that's what's going to happen as long
as you believe it that's what's going to
happen so now you have a great
opportunity because that environment you
didn't pick it wasn't consciously
designed right you didn't pick your
parents you didn't pick everything that
is surrounding you right now you were
forced to go into an arranged marriage
now you get the shift everything you
need to design an environment that
supports you and your big goals you want
to build a business empire create an
environment that supports empire
building so when you go into wherever
you're going to work if you're working
on a home office you go into a company
office whatever it is those stories that
you're telling you somebody
entrepreneurs I'm being too old put up
pictures of Ellen and Lady Gaga and
calvin klein and Harland Sanders and Ray
Kroc put them on their walls surround
yourself with energy that supports your
big goal that busts through those myths
and that helps shatter that story that
you're telling yourself because until
you do that until you create that new
environment that supports you and allows
you to become the person that you want
to become until you create that
environment yourself with purpose
you're going to continue to stay where
you are and I feel I feel the pain and I
feel the desire to want to bust through
right that's why you're asking this
question so take this opportunity now to
create an environment that surrounds
yourself with inspiring stories things
that make you believe in yourself more
things that build you up and start to
eliminate the things that just keep
holding you where you are when you
change your environment you'll change
your life believe those you watching
like the video you can subscribe to the
channel see more just like it thank you
so much and I'll see you soon don't
forget to click here to subscribe to my
newsletter to get actionable inspiring
motivational believe advice every single
week to your inbox hi I'm Jason Jiro's
fonseka of ra's online com and i want to
say Evan Carmichael's newsletter is
consistent fun inspiring and XD only
newsletter I prioritize and look forward
to period